Jake: 在冲完牛奶之后
Jake: After you finish mixing the milk...
Tasha:  没事我来
Tasha: It's okay, I'll do it.
Lucia: 可以我们可以选一下
Lucia: Sure, we can choose one.
Jake: 哦对对然后你们可以在这比划比划
Jake: Oh yeah, and you can practice here.
Alice: 你们家里面鸡蛋饼是比较稀的
Alice: Is the egg pancake in your home usually thin?
Jake: 因为相机都给你们布好了
Jake: Because I've set up the cameras for you.
Alice: 还是比较稠的
Alice: Or is it thick?
Jake: 哈哈哈二楼相机没有布好
Jake: Haha, the camera on the second floor isn't ready yet.
Tasha:  比较顺滑的
Tasha: It's more smooth.
Jake: 所以没办法上去比划
Jake: So you can't practice upstairs.
Lucia: 这里如果有美团的话地址
Lucia: If there's Meituan here, the address...
Jake: 地址是
Jake: The address is...
Jake: 玉河区30玉河区53号你可以直接对
Jake: Yuhe District, No. 30, Yuhe District, No. 53. You can directly...
Tasha:  筷子还得洗
Tasha: The chopsticks need washing.
Alice: 你这个不也得洗吗
Alice: Doesn't this need washing too?
Lucia: 50 53号
Lucia: 50, No. 53.
Alice: 这是怎么了
Alice: What happened?
Jake: 哦对就是把31改成53
Jake: Oh right, just change 31 to 53.
Jake: 因为31他找不到他要绕圈
Jake: Because he can't find 31, he has to go around in circles.
Lucia: 我的网络又开始不太给力
Lucia: My network is starting to get weak again.
Jake: 没关系
Jake: No worries.
Lucia: 要买一个碘伏我的脚蹭破了
Lucia: I need to buy some iodine solution, my foot got scraped.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 那我可以问问这个管家
Jake: I can ask the housekeeper about that.
Lucia: 如果他有的话
Lucia: If they have it.
Katrina:  这边他们是不打扫卫生是吗
Katrina: They don't clean here, do they?
Jake: 呃可以跟他们说他们就对
Jake: Uh, you can tell them, and they will, yeah.
Lucia: 可以让他来打扫应该
Lucia: You can ask them to clean, right?
Jake: 好
Jake: Sure.
Lucia: 为什么转不出来呢
Lucia: Why can't I get it to load?
Jake: 哎对京东是你要让让
Jake: Oh yeah, JD is... you need to...
Jake: 你什么时候去
Jake: When are you going?
Tasha:  下午他走了
Tasha: He's leaving in the afternoon.
Jake: 嗯OK
Jake: Mm, okay.
Katrina:  就是昨天我们拿快递那个
Katrina: It was when we picked up the package yesterday.
Tasha:  嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Katrina:  他不是固定的
Katrina: It's not fixed.
Tasha:  感觉这个村
Tasha: This village feels...
Lucia: 这和我连VPN有关系吗
Lucia: Does this have anything to do with my VPN?
Katrina:  外来人员
Katrina: Outsiders
Lucia: 但是我看对
Lucia: But I think it's correct
Katrina:  随时来探望我们一下
Katrina: They can visit us anytime
Jake: 卡住了是吗
Jake: Is it stuck?
Lucia: 我看我看
Lucia: Let me see, let me see
Jake: 应该没有什么
Jake: There shouldn't be any problem
Lucia: 您好像能正确使用美团
Lucia: You seem to be using Meituan correctly
Lucia: 我觉得应该不是这个原因
Lucia: I don't think that's the reason
Tasha:  啊没关系
Tasha: Ah, it's okay
Jake: 对美团的问题
Jake: About the Meituan issue
Tasha:  no not at all
Tasha: No, not at all
Lucia: 我退出来重新进一下
Lucia: I'll log out and log back in
Jake: 这是那次海底捞的视频
Jake: This is the Haidilao video from that time
Tasha:  还会再稀一点
Tasha: It can be a bit thinner
Tasha:  面水加多了加面面加多了加水
Tasha: Add more water to the noodles, if you add too much noodles, add more water
Lucia: 哎怎么回事啊
Lucia: Hey, what's going on?
Alice:是这样的
Alice: It's like this
Katrina: 需要在热水里泡
Katrina: You need to soak it in hot water
Jake: 这么多种子
Jake: So many seeds
Jake: 他要种什么东西
Jake: What are they going to plant?
Katrina:  这应该是土吧
Katrina: This should be soil, right?
Katrina:  这是草莓
Katrina: These are strawberries
Katrina:  这是赠送的樱桃萝卜
Katrina: These are bonus cherry radishes
Jake: 啊还能种樱桃
Jake: Ah, you can even grow cherries?
Alice:先放进去
Alice: Put it in first
Jake: 呵呵樱桃不是种很久吗
Jake: Haha, don't cherries take a long time to grow?
Katrina:  哈哈海底捞
Katrina: Haha, Haidilao
Katrina:  怎么海底捞的业务
Katrina: How's Haidilao's business?
Jake: 樱桃树你种过吗
Jake: Have you ever planted a cherry tree?
Katrina:  啊樱桃不是树吗
Katrina: Ah, isn't a cherry a tree?
Tasha:  吃过算吗
Tasha: Does eating them count?
Katrina:  他怎么能给我种呢
Katrina: How can he let me plant it?
Jake: 呵呵呵吃过差不多
Jake: Haha, eating them is almost the same
Alice: 你要的稠度吗
Alice: Is this the consistency you want?
Tasha:  还要再稀一点
Tasha: It needs to be a bit thinner
Alice: 那你得放水
Alice: Then you need to add water
Jake: 点上了吗
Jake: Did you click it?
Alice: 你就放这一点
Alice: Just add this much
Lucia: nope定位飘到外星球去了
Lucia: Nope, the GPS has drifted off to outer space
Tasha:  我又怕放多了
Tasha: I'm afraid of adding too much
Jake: 我帮你点
Jake: I'll help you out.
Alice: 没事我来了我就有点费劲
Alice: No worries, I'm just having a bit of trouble.
Lucia: 奇怪啊
Lucia: Weird.
Jake: 你用的是美团外卖是吧
Jake: You're using Meituan Waimai, right?
Lucia: 对就我直接点了美团的APP然后它里面会有这个
Lucia: Yeah, I just clicked on the Meituan app and it should have this.
Lucia: 刚才里面已经搞好了但是它突然又不对了
Lucia: It was all set up just now, but then it suddenly stopped working.
Tasha:  我在想要不要那个搅拌器
Tasha: I'm wondering if we need a mixer.
Lucia: 51号是吗
Lucia: Is it number 51?
Tasha:  会不会搅拌的更顺一点
Tasha: Would it blend more smoothly?
Jake:  53
Jake: 53.
Lucia: 53 嗯
Lucia: 53, got it.
Tasha:  感觉有颗粒感
Tasha: It feels a bit grainy.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 我是输入53吗
Lucia: Should I enter 53?
Alice: 你不是要弄更多吗
Alice: Weren't you going to do more?
Lucia: 因为我看他那里还有一个
Lucia: Because I saw there's another one there.
Lucia: 就是就算你输入
Lucia: So even if you enter it...
Lucia: 他要你选定位还是什么的
Lucia: It still asks you to select a location or something.
Jake: 您直接输就好了
Jake: Just enter it directly.
Jake: 应该把那个53号
Jake: You should put in that 53.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Okay.
Tasha:  他最后就是滑起来没有阻力的那种
Tasha: In the end, it should slide smoothly with no resistance.
Jake: 或者你用我这个号
Jake: Or you could use my account.
Tasha:  你懂我的状态吗
Tasha: Do you get what I mean?
Lucia: 为什么你的可以正常使用呢
Lucia: Why does yours work fine?
Alice: 蛋液应该后放
Alice: The egg mixture should go in later.
Jake: 因为我是美团外卖
Jake: Because I'm using Meituan Waimai.
Jake: 美团我也不太
Jake: I don't really...
Alice: 因为蛋液一放进去
Alice: Because once you put the egg mixture in...
Jake: 我也不怎么用
Jake: I don't use it much.
Alice: 他把那个面给裹住了
Alice: It coats the dough.
Lucia: 哦我看一下您这个
Lucia: Oh, let me take a look at yours.
Jake: 我不知道美团有可能也有用
Jake: I don't know, maybe Meituan also has this feature.
Alice: 还好
Alice: It's okay.
Alice: 没关系早饭而已
Alice: No worries, it's just breakfast.
Lucia: 里面
Lucia: Inside...
Lucia: 你的APP名字就叫美团外卖
Lucia: Your app is just called Meituan Waimai?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 我再下个APP我
Lucia: I'll download another app then.
Katrina:  舞蹈
Katrina: Dance.
Alice: 是你要的是再稀一点还是
Alice: Do you want it to be a bit more watery or...
Tasha:  我靠怎么这么稠真的是用低筋面粉吗
Tasha: Wow, why is it so thick? Are you sure you used low-gluten flour?
Tasha:  我怎么记得是用糯米粉
Tasha: I remember it should be glutinous rice flour.
Alice:什么 糯米粉
Alice: What? Glutinous rice flour?
Tasha:  糯米粉我们家好像用糯米粉
Tasha: Yeah, I think we use glutinous rice flour at home.
Katrina:  那我们跳舞是不是还要带上修硕一起
Katrina: Should we bring Shure along when we dance?
Lucia: 我也在想
Lucia: I was thinking the same.
Lucia: 至少我们练的时候要大家要带上
Lucia: At least when we practice, everyone should be there.
Lucia: 那会很影响
Lucia: It might affect things.
Katrina:  上再教他也没事
Katrina: We can teach him, it's no big deal.
Lucia: 会影响一些动作
Lucia: It might affect some moves.
Katrina:  不是如果是有男生加入的话
Katrina: If a guy joins, the dance style will...
Katrina:  那个舞蹈风格就
Katrina: It will change.
Jake: 你可以不加入
Jake: You can join or not.
Jake: 也可以加入都是你们说了算
Jake: It's up to you guys.
Lucia: 要不就加入吧
Lucia: How about he joins then?
Lucia: 让人多一点
Lucia: It will make us more.
Katrina:  来吧一起社死吧
Katrina: Come on, let's all embarrass ourselves together.
Lucia: 显得有气势一些显得有
Lucia: It will make us look more powerful.
Katrina:  我找找
Katrina: I'll check.
Katrina:  我问问我同学他们之前挑过什么
Katrina: I'll ask my classmates what they've done before.
Tasha:  天呐感觉很失败哈哈哈
Tasha: Oh my god, this feels like a failure, hahaha.
Alice: 你放调料了吗
Alice: Did you add any seasoning?
Tasha:  没有不是加糖吗
Tasha: No, aren't we supposed to add sugar?
Lucia: 但我觉得我这次穿来的衣服里面
Lucia: But I think the best outfit I brought is...
Lucia: 最适合的可能就是这条
Lucia: This pair of pants and the white top.
Lucia: 这条裤子和那个白色上衣了
Lucia: 所以
Lucia: So...
Lucia: 我们也可以不那么统一
Lucia: We don't have to be that uniform.
Alice: 哎等一下这个是你想要的稠度吗
Alice: Wait a second, is this the consistency you want?
Lucia: 就是服装风格差不多就可以了
Lucia: The style just needs to be similar.
Tasha:  可以吧差不多就这样吧
Tasha: Yeah, this should be fine.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 你放糖进去
Alice: Did you add the sugar?
Jake: 或者自己做
Jake: Or do it yourself.
Alice: 直接这样放糖它会不会不融化呀
Alice: If you add the sugar directly, will it dissolve?
Lucia: 节省一些预算
Lucia: To save some budget.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  直接穿那种纸质的衣服
Katrina: Just wear paper clothes.
Alice: 你是不是得调糖水或者怎么的
Alice: Should we make sugar syrup or something?
Lucia: 我们的杯子在那边OK
Lucia: Our cups are over there, OK.
Katrina:  哎这好苦
Katrina: Ugh, this is so bitter.
Jake: 也也不一定
Jake: Not necessarily.
Jake: 自己做不一定节省预预算
Jake: Making it yourself doesn't necessarily save the budget.
Lucia: 是吗
Lucia: Really?
Katrina:  我加了他倒进来就这么多
Katrina: I added this much, and he poured in this much.
Katrina:  然后我加了这么多牛奶还是很苦
Katrina: Then I added this much milk, and it's still bitter.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 那都有谁喝咖啡啊
Lucia: So, who else drinks coffee?
Lucia: 我统计一下
Lucia: Let me count.
Lucia: 不喝咖啡的啊
Lucia: Who doesn't drink coffee?
Alice: 我来一个吧
Alice: I'll have one.
Lucia: 你喝吗
Lucia: Do you drink?
Jake: 来喝我也喝
Jake: Yes, I do.
Tasha:  我要喝牛奶
Tasha: I want milk.
Lucia: 呃要咖里面要不要咖啡您算上了
Lucia: Uh, do you want coffee in it? Are you counted?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 雨轩还喝咖啡吗不喝
Lucia: Does Yuxuan still drink coffee? No?
Katrina:  这密Wifi密码
Katrina: This secret Wifi password...
Jake: 哎呀挡住了挡住了挡住了
Jake: Oh, it's blocking, blocking, blocking.
Lucia: 那现在就两个人OK
Lucia: So now there are just two people, OK.
Jake: 对也挡住了
Jake: Yes, it's blocking.
Katrina:  Wifi密码是多少上来的
Katrina: What's the Wifi password?
Jake: 这儿
Jake: Here.
Alice: 我来一个吧
Alice: I'll have one.
Jake: 怎么还有指纹呢
Jake: Why is there a fingerprint?
Tasha:  来一个什么
Tasha: Have what?
Alice: 喝的
Alice: A drink.
Tasha:  你刚刚不是报名了咖啡吗
Tasha: Didn't you just sign up for coffee?
Alice: 对啊但是我又取消了
Alice: Yeah, but I canceled it.
Alice: 我现在报一下
Alice: I'll sign up now.
Lucia: 啊那你重新报名
Lucia: Ah, then sign up again.
Lucia: 哈哈我们的咖啡名额减少到一个
Lucia: Haha, our coffee quota is reduced to one.
Alice: 刚刚已经把我算上了总共才两个
Alice: I was already counted earlier, so there are just two total.
Lucia: 对对因为我我我现在不是特别困
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, because I'm not particularly sleepy right now.
Lucia: 所以我先不喝
Lucia: So I won't drink.
Lucia: 然后雨轩刚已经喝过了
Lucia: And Yuxuan already had one.
Lucia: 那你喝什么呢
Lucia: So what do you want to drink?
Alice: 咖啡吧
Alice: Coffee.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha:  哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哎呀哈哈
Lucia: Oh my gosh, haha
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Lucia: 对方撤出撤回了一条消息又发送了
Lucia: The other person retracted a message and sent it again
Lucia: 一样的是吧
Lucia: It's the same, right?
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 剩下的人都喝牛奶吗
Lucia: Are the rest of you just drinking milk?
Lucia: 嗯找一个小锅什么的
Lucia: Hmm, find a small pot or something
Jake: 路亚是买好了吗
Jake: Did you buy the lure already?
Tasha:  感觉水有点多
Tasha: Feels like there's too much water
Lucia: 啊什么啊还没呢
Lucia: Oh, what? Not yet
Jake: 买好还买
Jake: Buy it again?
Jake: 那我先放在
Jake: I'll put it first
Jake: 或者我联系一下修硕
Jake: Or I can contact Shure
Jake: 哎先联系一下收垃圾
Jake: Hey, let's contact the garbage collector first
Lucia: 或许可以问一下他们
Lucia: Maybe we can ask them
Lucia: 就是民宿这边有没有碘伏或者酒精
Lucia: If the guesthouse has any iodine or alcohol
Jake: 嗯嗯好
Jake: Okay, sure
Lucia: 因为我我刚刷了一下
Lucia: Because I just refreshed it
Lucia: 他还没有刷新出来
Lucia: It hasn't refreshed yet
Katrina:  你们听过这个歌吗
Katrina: Have you heard this song?
Katrina:  就这个舞很简单
Katrina: This dance is really simple
Lucia: 我好像听过让我看一眼
Lucia: I think I've heard it, let me take a look
Katrina:  非常简单
Katrina: Very simple
Katrina:  就是人家跳年会的舞
Katrina: It's the dance people do at annual parties
Katrina:  这是我们之前艺术团跳过跳着玩的
Katrina: We used to dance it for fun in our art troupe
Lucia: 这个是一个抖音上很火的曲子吗
Lucia: Is this a popular song on TikTok?
Lucia: 觉得我好像在哪里听过
Lucia: I feel like I've heard it somewhere
Katrina:  钥匙
Katrina: The key
Jake: 这是一个经典的一个
Jake: It's a classic one
Katrina:  非常经典的
Katrina: Very classic
Jake: 这这是哪年
Jake: Which year is this from?
Jake: 零几年的歌还是八几年的歌呀
Jake: Is it from the 2000s or the 80s?
Katrina:  嗯呵
Katrina: Hmm
Katrina:  失恋阵线联盟
Katrina: "Love Line of Defense"
Jake: 这可能是八几年的歌
Jake: It might be from the 80s
Katrina:  倒是很简单
Katrina: But it's very simple
Lucia: 哎对这个
Lucia: Oh right, this one
Tasha:  我发给他了吗
Tasha: Did I send it to him?
Lucia: 这个还蛮简单的
Lucia: This is quite simple.
Katrina:  就当时我们艺术团
Katrina: Back when we were in the art troupe,
Katrina:  男生可以跳的
Katrina: the boys could dance too.
Katrina:  多长时间
Katrina: How long?
Katrina:  2分42 跳个2分钟
Katrina: 2 minutes and 42 seconds, just dance for 2 minutes.
Katrina:  就跳个1分钟就可以了
Katrina: Just dance for 1 minute, that's enough.
Lucia: 而且动作幅度也不大
Lucia: And the movements aren't that big.
Lucia: 其实整体来说戴个眼镜也没什么怪
Lucia: Actually, overall, wearing glasses doesn't look weird.
Lucia: 你看他们也戴着呢哈哈哈
Lucia: Look, they're wearing glasses too, haha.
Katrina:  哎对哦
Katrina: Oh, right.
Alice: 薇薇好了
Alice: Tasha is ready.
Katrina:  我们可以搞一点造型pose
Katrina: We can strike some poses.
Katrina:  一棵树哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Like a tree, hahaha.
Lucia: 啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Ahahaha.
Lucia: 1棵树动作幅度这么大吗
Lucia: Does a tree pose require such big movements?
Katrina:  搞一个那个树的头套
Katrina: Let's get a tree headpiece.
Tasha:  那个铜锣烧是不是用低筋面粉
Tasha: Is dorayaki made with low-gluten flour?
Lucia: 他现在加载出来了
Lucia: It's loading now.
Katrina:  哦还有个你你你跳舞吗
Katrina: Oh, and you, do you dance?
Katrina:  这不是修硕最爱的摇滚吗
Katrina: Isn't this Shure's favorite rock music?
Tasha:  糯米粉好吧
Tasha: Glutinous rice flour, right?
Tasha:  算了不学了
Tasha: Never mind, I won't learn it.
Katrina:  这也可以
Katrina: This works too.
Katrina:  当我们毕设
Katrina: For our final project.
Tasha:  啊我想要换个容器
Tasha: Ah, I want to change the container.
Lucia: 为什么这个
Lucia: Why this one?
Lucia: 看起来有一点哈哈
Lucia: It looks a bit, haha.
Jake: 你们想要换房间
Jake: Do you want to change rooms?
Katrina:  哎呦这还有一点什么元素呢
Katrina: Oh, there's some kind of element here.
Jake: 你你你们想要打扫房间吗
Jake: Do you want to clean the room?
Tasha:  呃我只是想过筛一下
Tasha: Uh, I just want to sift it.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  还有换队形
Katrina: And change the formation.
Lucia: 是我们要现在收拾一下扫描吗
Lucia: Do we need to tidy up and scan now?
Jake: 呃也不是
Jake: Uh, not really.
Jake: 就是可以换
Jake: But we can change.
Tasha:  嗯也好过吧
Tasha: Hmm, that's fine too.
Katrina:  哎这好看
Katrina: Oh, this looks nice.
Jake: 可以这个哎
Jake: This one, yeah.
Katrina:  这比刚刚那好看
Katrina: This looks better than before.
Alice: 呃那你试试吧
Alice: Uh, then you try it.
Jake: 也可以啊
Jake: That works too.
Katrina:  这还有点hip Hop元素
Katrina: This has a bit of hip-hop elements.
Jake: 晚上我们也不是晚上
Jake: In the evening, or rather, not evening.
Tasha:  因为感觉里面有颗粒
Tasha: Because it feels like there are particles inside.
Jake: 可能下午我们就扫一下
Jake: Maybe in the afternoon we can sweep a bit.
Jake: 他们先帮你们扫一下
Jake: They can help you sweep first.
Jake: 你们再整理一下应该就好对
Jake: Then you can tidy up a bit and it should be fine.
Tasha:  但这个这个网确实太密了
Tasha: But this net is really too dense.
Lucia: 哦也可以
Lucia: Oh, that works too.
Tasha:  哇像芝士
Tasha: Wow, like cheese.
Tasha:  完了
Tasha: It's over.
Tasha:  买的网太密了
Tasha: The net we bought is too dense.
Tasha:  我靠
Tasha: Oh crap.
Tasha:  玛莎卡
Tasha: Mashaka.
Alice: 我之前做章鱼小丸子的时候试过过筛
Alice: I tried sifting when I made takoyaki before.
Katrina:  这这怎么又是SOLO
Katrina: Why is it solo again?
Alice: 确实不好过筛
Alice: It's really hard to sift.
Tasha:  等一下
Tasha: Wait a minute.
Katrina:  这咱就奇怪了
Katrina: This is just weird.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Lucia: 我们可以把那个男生的站位给他删掉
Lucia: We can just remove the boys' positions.
Lucia: 反正我们也没那么多人
Lucia: We don't have that many people anyway.
Tasha:  稍等我一下
Tasha: Hold on a sec.
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey.
Katrina:  偶像万万岁哦我想起来了
Katrina: Idol forever, oh I remember.
Katrina:  高中的一个舞
Katrina: A dance from high school.
Alice: 真的熟了之后没啥区别
Alice: Once you get used to it, there's no difference.
Katrina:  还有女团舞
Katrina: And a girl group dance.
Katrina:  哈哈哈先开始
Katrina: Hahaha, let's start.
Katrina:  收藏一下吧
Katrina: Let's save it.
Katrina:  嗯还有那个偶像万万岁
Katrina: Hmm, and that idol forever.
Alice: 因为我之前做章鱼小丸子时候过筛
Alice: Because when I sifted for takoyaki before.
Katrina:  是要搞嗨一点的歌
Katrina: It needs to be a more hype song.
Alice: 他不是更细
Alice: It was finer.
Tasha: 更细腻 对
Tasha: Finer, right.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 买的吗就是
Jake: Did you buy it?
Alice: 但是就是我那时候
Alice: But at that time.
Alice: 就是跟这种稠度差不多的那个
Alice: It was about the same consistency.
Lucia: 出大门左转
Lucia: Turn left after you exit the gate.
Alice: 过筛真是艰难的要死
Alice: Sifting is so darn difficult.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Got it.
Tasha:  巨难过筛
Tasha: Sifting is super hard.
Lucia: 啊他没有碘伏是吧
Lucia: Ah, he doesn't have iodine, right?
Lucia: 那我就在美团订一个
Lucia: Then I'll order one on Meituan.
Tasha:  好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Jake: 嗯哦哦OK
Jake: Mm, oh, okay.
Lucia: 刚才已经找好了
Lucia: I already found it earlier.
Katrina:  还有我的未来事业
Katrina: And my future career.
Tasha:  OK上锅
Tasha: Okay, put it on the stove.
Lucia: 53号楼OK
Lucia: Building 53, okay.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Mm.
Alice:油
Alice: Oil.
Tasha:  什么
Tasha: What?
Alice: 油在这
Alice: The oil is here.
Tasha:  铲子
Tasha: Spatula.
Alice: 这个能高温不能
Alice: Can this withstand high heat?
Katrina:  好像广播体操
Katrina: Feels like a radio exercise.
Tasha:  这个不能
Tasha: This one can't.
Alice: 不能
Alice: Can't.
Lucia: 玉河区53号楼
Lucia: Building 53, Yuhe District.
Tasha:  嗯
Tasha: Mm.
Tasha:  我靠这铲子怎么这么油
Tasha: Damn, why is this spatula so oily?
Tasha:  受不了了好黏糊
Tasha: I can't stand it, it's so sticky.
Lucia: 隐私保护中
Lucia: Privacy protection in progress.
Alice:我喝凉的就行
Alice: I'll just drink it cold.
Lucia: 完全像这样
Lucia: Exactly like this.
Alice: 不用给我弄热的
Alice: No need to heat it up for me.
Lucia: 呃没事反正牛奶会变成热的
Lucia: Uh, no worries, the milk will turn warm anyway.
Lucia: 所以你也可以加热牛奶
Lucia: So you can heat the milk too.
Lucia: 万一你in case you change your mind
Lucia: Just in case you change your mind.
Jake: 哈哈哈有了一手啊
Jake: Hahaha, got a trick up your sleeve, huh?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Tasha:  什么
Tasha: What?
Alice: no no no no no
Alice: No, no, no, no, no.
Alice: 我不喝我不喝热的
Alice: I won't drink it hot.
Jake: 哈哈哈有了一手
Jake: Hahaha, got a trick up your sleeve.
Alice: 牛奶我喝凉的就行了啊
Alice: I'll just drink cold milk, alright?
Tasha:  啊不要放在这里
Tasha: Ah, don't put it here.
Lucia: 啊不要放在这里啊
Lucia: Ah, don't put it here.
Lucia: 不我不我不放
Lucia: No, I won't, I won't put it.
Lucia: 我啊你你的意思是你要用这个锅是吗
Lucia: Oh, you mean you want to use this pot, right?
Tasha:  哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 啊没有没有我不用这个锅
Lucia: No, no, I won't use this pot.
Lucia: 我只是把这个在这里放一下
Lucia: I'm just putting this here for a bit.
Lucia: 然后找一个锅给它倒进去而已
Lucia: Then I'll find another pot to pour it into.
Lucia: 他这里有没有那种专门的牛奶壶
Lucia: Do they have a special milk pot here?
Lucia: 感觉好像没有什么呃
Lucia: Feels like there's none, uh...
Alice: 应该不会有
Alice: There probably isn't.
Lucia: 让我再看看
Lucia: Let me check again.
Lucia: 因为如果没有的话
Lucia: Because if there isn't,
Lucia: 那个那个锅用来热牛奶就太大了
Lucia: that pot is too big to heat milk.
Lucia: 感觉一个热进去才能把他
Lucia: Feels like you'd need to heat a lot to cover the bottom.
Lucia: 才能把他盖到底的感觉
Lucia: Feels like you'd need a lot to cover the bottom.
Lucia: 让我再看看
Lucia: Let me check again.
Alice: 我们都是用这种杯子是吗
Alice: We all use this kind of cup, right?
Lucia: 好像只有
Lucia: Seems like
Lucia: 这种杯子耶
Lucia: it's just these cups.
Alice: 哦对好的
Alice: Oh, right, okay.
Alice: 那我洗一个吧
Alice: Then I'll wash one.
Lucia: 但是你也可以用碗
Lucia: But you can also use a bowl.
Tasha:  怎么办第一次用这种锅
Tasha: What to do, first time using this pot.
Alice: 好给外国人一点震撼
Alice: Okay, let's surprise the foreigners a bit.
Lucia: 我觉这个锅用来热牛奶也太
Lucia: I think this pot is too...
Lucia: 哈哈也太
Lucia: Haha, too...
Lucia: 但是好像没有别的锅了
Lucia: But seems like there's no other pot.
Alice: 放油了吗
Alice: Did you put oil?
Tasha:  放了
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 要不就暂且用这个吧
Lucia: How about we just use this for now.
Tasha:  我没有用过这个锅煎饼
Tasha: I've never used this pot to make pancakes.
Alice: 啊这这油有点多
Alice: Ah, there's a bit too much oil.
Tasha:  有点多是吧哈哈
Tasha: A bit too much, huh? Haha.
Alice: 就这样我我
Alice: Just like this, I...
Tasha:  那倒出来一些吧
Tasha: Then pour out some.
Alice: 你你没地方倒吧
Alice: You don't have anywhere to pour it, right?
Alice: 你就那样吧
Alice: Just leave it like that.
Alice: 留在锅里一点也没事
Alice: It's okay to leave a bit in the pot.
Alice: 抽油烟机抽油烟机
Alice: Turn on the range hood.
Tasha:  啊好好好熏呀
Tasha: Ah, okay, okay, it's smoky.
Alice: 别闻这个味
Alice: Don't smell this.
Alice: 这个味太
Alice: The smell is too...
Alice: 火还可以
Alice: The heat is okay.
Alice: 小心一点
Alice: Be careful.